[Musique]
fatima fatma et inès sont arrivés au
québec avec leur famille
il y a moins de 5 ans fatima zahra
fusillé d'origine marocaine je suis au
québec depuis 2015 et effusions deuxième
année en éducation préscolaire
enseignement primaire
fatma et la [ __ ] étudiante à
l'université de montréal en enseignement
primaire au préscolaire
je suis là depuis 2015 et je suis
algérienne inès boutiche originaire
d'algérie je suis arrivé ici au québec
en 2016 je suis en deuxième année
éducation préscolaire et enseignement
primaire elle enseignait déjà dans leur
pays d'origine pour travailler ici elles
ont dû reprendre leurs études
un choix réfléchi pour améliorer leur
sort mais le projet de loi 21 sur la
laïcité est venu jeter un pavé dans la
mare comment vous prévoyez votre avenir
6,7 ce projet de loi devient la loi nous
l'enseignement si je passe entre nous
c'est une vocation donc c'était un choix
on a investi du temps d'investir de
l'argent
donc c'est vraiment difficile pour nous
on va pas notre avenir qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire on sait pas ce qui va se
passer par la suite est ce que je peux
faire mon stage est ce que je peux
enseigner dans une école
donc c'est vraiment délicat moi j'étais
sélectionnée comme travailleurs
qualifiés ils m'ont expliqué que je peux
travailler ici au québec il y aura aucun
problème par rapport aux signes
religieux
j'étais enseignante donc c'est ça en
arrivant ici je refais mon bac je suis à
mi chemin ils me disent que je ne peux
pas continuer je ne sais pas quoi faire
à part l'enseignement
qu'est ce que le voile représente pour
vous c'est important ça fait partie de
moi c'est un choix évident
je sais que vous voulez qu'on vous dise
et religieux oui ces religieux ça fait
partie de ma religion mais ça reste mon
choix personne ne m'a obligé à le faire
c'est une identité tout simplement oui
et pour vous ça fait partie de moi
ça fait partie de ma personnalité ça
fait partie de fatim en terrain positif
je ne peux pas changer ça la question
fondamentale ici c'est le voile est ce
que vous envisagez d'enlever votre voile
non pourquoi
c'était un choix personnel de mettre le
voile et mon voile n'ont aucun impact
n'a aucune influence
je le mets où je le mets pas je reste
madame fatima pour les élèves
ça change rien dans ma personnalité je
suis toujours la même personne et vous
madame est ce que vous seriez prête à
enlever votre noah du tout pourquoi
c'est pas du tout envisageable
c'est un choix personnel ja c'est pas
une personne qui m'a obligé à lemaitre
et c'est pas monsieur legault qui va
m'obliger à l'enlever quand ont été
sélectionnés on été sélectionné avec
nous si ni religieux j'ai passé
l'entrevue avec une madame quand vous et
je lui demandé clairement est ce que mon
voile va poser un problème pour trouver
un emploi elle était très l'arrêt pas sa
réponse était très clair et très
encourageante elle m'a dit madame au
québec
vous êtes libre ces trois femmes ont
participé à la manifestation de dimanche
dernier à montréal pour signifier leur
volonté de s'intégrer dans leur pays
d'adoption avec leurs différences si
vous aviez un message pour monsieur
legault ce serait quoi aujourd'hui je
lui dirais de d'oublier ce que j'ai sur
la tête et de regarder plutôt ce que
j'ai dans la tête je suis qualifié et
j'ai été sélectionné pour venir aussi et
québec donc chez c'était certes mon
choix on a choisi de venir de venir ici
mais c'était gagnant gagnant dans
l'histoire
pensez à nous en tant qu'être humain
penser à l'intérêt à l'intégration nous
on cherche d'être intégrés l'intégration
de nos enfants
comment moi je pourrais expliquer à mon
enfant que toi tu aies accepté mais ta
maman n'ait pas accepté c'est
et puis si le sentiment d'être expulsé
allez-y on veut pas vous la partir à une
autre province
ça fait mal au coeur
[Musique]